jason welcome to the podcast
thank you hisham how are you doing
good it's been a little while i've
haven't been the best at get making this
happen
so i'm excited
it's happening now
obviously for everyone
listening was really really keen and
excited to
to get you booked in and have this
conversation with you was
as i'm sure
you've obviously really picked up on and
seen there's definitely a real trend
right now in terms of
a lot of uk based companies expanding
growing going over to the states
and obviously obviously in preparation
for this
you told me that you actually
set up your us entity in 2014
so a bit before maybe the major trend of
the uk
recruitment company so really excited to
to dig into yeah the journey over the
last nine years um with your your own
recruitment business and have a real
focus on the american part of that
journey
i guess where we always like to start is
the million dollar million pound
question which i'm sure you've thought a
lot about since growing and hiring for
your own business so i'd love to hear
your take on what you believe
sort of makes up a highly successful
modern day recruiter the characteristics
of traits that you feel they they may
share in common
cool so thanks for having me on first of
all um i think just on that question
specifically i think i've seen over the
years from
myself kind of joining uh an xs3 kind of
business owner at iit talent
where most of it um used to be kind of
all about money people that are money
hungry would be great recruitment i
think over the years i've started to see
more kind of introverts and extroverts
that can given the right training in
time can actually work really well in
recruitment so i think some some kind of
words that i'd say that come to mind
that people that are disciplined
uh people with a 360 mindset uh people
that like to network um but also people
who have the passion for the markets
that they're actually in uh are people
that i've seen do really well
and are really successful in industry
360 mindset something about that what do
you mean by that so just someone that's
always looking for new business doesn't
matter where they are and can be on the
train can be at different events can be
with family can be with friends
um but just having that kind of always
looking to network um because
sometimes the best connections we have
are with
friends and family uh and we actually
don't go out to them as often as we
maybe should do
strangest environment that you picked up
a client then i have to ask you that i'm
sorry you started with like
a train
party like i don't know any story any
story there out of interest i had to ask
um
that's going back a bit
it's probably probably when i'm drunk at
a club sometimes i i used to always
carry yeah i used to always have um
kind of business cards with me yeah
exactly old school way of doing it um
so yeah i i used to kind of always carry
them around and most likely picked up um
actually one of our biggest clients was
from someone that was
uh
an event and they were outside in the
smoking area and just happened to
to talk to someone and get connected
yeah
yeah yeah that's interesting yeah i had
to ask that
with what you use that's all good you
said that
was going to say so i guess before we go
into the entrepreneurial journey just
always like to ask this because so many
people fall into industry
i think way more people should be
choosing the industry and there's a big
part where i started this podcast so i'd
love to just to just hear your take on
like what what a career and
yeah a long time recruitment has given
you your life professionally personally
what has it given you that maybe you
least expected
well i guess i i kind of expected gray
hairs and and almost being born from it
but i guess that's probably most people
uh i i think
that the the attraction to recruitment i
think um most people kind of well i
certainly kind of fell into recruitment
like most uh it's not something that i
was looking to do
during university but i think it
definitely has opened my eyes and ears
to being able to travel the world in
terms of what we do and
just starting from a junior recruiter
into eventually kind of running my own
company um so i think with that has kind
of lots of challenges and i think that
the fact that the industry is so
fast-paced that there's so much to offer
uh the fact that you can kind of go from
uh having
zero experience to
two to three years experience of being
able to be approached to be head-hunted
by companies in a different
country a different continent uh you
can't really get that with most other
industries usually you have to wait uh
for someone uh to come knocking at your
doors and have at least five to ten
years of experience but i think the the
yeah the incredible thing about
recruitment is you can kind of yeah go
from one to the next very quickly
all about hard work usually
okay
so let let's go into this entrepreneur
entrepreneurial journey of yours then so
i'm gonna just start
by just framing up for people and then
plea please correct me or just just let
me know if i've missed something or
whatever but i think with these types of
things it always helps just give people
a bit of context sure so in terms of
like where where you are today
uh i think obviously the the number that
i put down is like yeah you're like 46
47 people
in terms of headcount wise right yes um
and i think obviously you've been on
this trajectory of growth
um obviously during and and post covered
as what i got down here is like pre-code
you're around the sort of 20 head head
count mark right
so
obviously founded were you the solo
founder of yours yes yes yeah i was a
solo founder and brought in a business
partner um who actually was my
accountant and actually a close friend
who's non
yeah
and so
um
yeah he comes more from an ops kind of
legal finance sector and
he was going to sell his company we were
always planning on doing something but
he was going to sell his last company
that he was ceo of um
pending the brexit result and after that
didn't go through he was like okay now
it's a good time to join um it was
mainly kind of when
i moved across from the uk to the us
which was interesting this 2015.
yeah ever since that um kind of time we
kind of work like chalk and cheese and
um yeah it works really well so when did
you start the company
2013 2013 yeah okay cool 13 yeah because
i had to 2009 for some reason don't know
where i've got that from i think 2009
was when i got into recruitment okay
right yeah got you okay so yeah start so
okay founded the business 2013 like you
said you then actually moved to the the
states in 2015
right
specifically um la
and then so that that's a good milestone
there and then obviously in terms of
like the words that you're recruiting
obviously what i've got down here we've
got tech engineering go to market team
data science analytics and then
obviously you've got another brand that
you recently invested in renewable
energy
um
and then what i also jotted down here is
obviously in terms of like
the type of business that you do but you
don't just do
contingent recruitment you've got people
that do 360 recruitment but yeah you've
got rpo you've got different solutions
that you obviously offer to your clients
and your customers
um so in terms of the actual us market
so were you obviously serving that or
focusing on that before you went over in
2015 so how long have you been operating
and doing business in the states so i
guess in terms of
the state so i i got into crypto and
blockchain super early so i'm talking
2013 um i was hiring mostly across
fintech companies in the uk and europe
and saw a gap in the market started
reaching out to companies in san
francisco and la which is where most of
the hubs were so a lot of them were
raising tons of money didn't see many
competitors and was doing that for a
while of kind of reaching out to
companies still had uk customers
and was had a small team in in the uk
there but when i started to see the kind
of the salary ranges and the money that
these people had i was like okay cool i
need to kind of get some momentum here
and within 18 months i ended up moving
over to the us so
um
i think i put up a
message on linkedin and someone i used
to work with was actually in toronto um
and looking to move over to california
so set up the company with him over
there and had a small team uh that that
didn't work out um for various reasons
within like
12 18 months and uh decided to
yeah kind of move away from that um but
yeah it was in la i actually wanted to
move to san francisco my wife wanted to
live in l.a we chose l.a
probably more for the sun but also
if i was going to be hiring recruiters
over from the uk which we did um it's
probably a better place for people to be
based just because of
the sun and it's probably slightly
cheaper than san francisco yeah sure
okay so you've been so basically been so
that means you've been operating doing
business all these types of things for
what's happening what seven years then
exactly yeah yeah okay cool um amazing
and then final thing that just be useful
what what did you do turnover wise last
year last financial yeah uh i think
we're like
12 15 12 to 13 million
okay awesome so like what i love about
this i'm so excited to get your thoughts
on this in terms of like
how you've evolved
uh your business in the american market
and these things because a lot of people
just starting this or in their first
year right
so i guess like let's let's firstly just
focus on more on like the traction so
what i mean by that on like you building
a brand there doing business there and
building a loyal client base all these
types of things and then let's then
segue into how jason has gone about
building a recruitment business over
there the culture how you've attracted
people and those things
so when it comes to
i guess the attraction side of things i
guess the first thing that just be good
to get your perspective on
was like yeah what what the go to market
strategy look like
so i guess
like i think obviously you said that you
were doing you were doing you and you're
reaching out to people while she was in
the uk and then you went over there but
like what was thinking thinking back and
i'm going to ask you what you would do
differently but how did you approach it
what was the go-to-market strategy then
in 2015 or before around then
so
i think
it doesn't really change from from one
market to the next in my personal
opinion
i've always had a great network always
been able to kind of pick up business at
conferences or whatever but really
specking out candidates is is is how
people grow market um especially kind of
when i was initially kind of reaching
out to crypto companies um like i said i
saw a lot of these companies raising and
um was working with a ton of people um
so it wasn't really any of the clients i
picked up were uk clients who had just
set up in the us it was more me doing
the old bd methods i used to do
and picked up clients that way but in
the us
okay fair enough and then from what you
know now about the market anything you
do differently does that still work i
know there's not like a silver bullet
but
if you're if you're
speaking to someone about growing a desk
from scratch in the u.s now what would
be the sort of strategy what would be
some of the key things that you think
would be
key to to make sure that it's successful
or you have the best chance of it being
successful
i think that's a part of it um i i think
if you look at the the people that we
have here in teletech uh you'll see a
lot of our uh recruiters generally have
like five to 15 years of
of recruiting experience so with that
generally comes with people that have
been building markets over the last five
to 15 years and still
specking works going to conferences
works
but generally we have we work with a lot
of vcs and we plug in there so we have a
lot of inbound coming into us from
referrals from vcs referrals from some
of the founders one of our clients who i
worked as worked in back in 2014
um he was like a 20 year old kid
stanford drop out
he his company i think has raised over
900 million in our series e uh valuation
and and
he's i think he's on the forbes list of
like one of the top five billionaires um
in the world right now we've hired for
tons of his companies he keeps on doing
intros um so it's stuff like that a lot
of these people are super super smart
that we work with in the us so
white combinator esk and people from
harvard stanford etc who some of the
brightest kind of brains out there so
um yeah i think that's kind of come just
down to the growth that we've had and
just from our name being around for so
long i think a lot of
people kind of
like to work with people that they know
or been referred more so maybe in the in
the us than in the uk
yeah no absolutely so what you touched
on a little bit on there but like for
people listening
it may be
let's be really frank and honest here
like it takes
time uh to
be in a position where someone like that
is is making consistent introductions it
takes you proving and delivering how
good your services these things but i
guess from your experience for people
listening that want to get into that
position where they've got some really
good relationships with people that
refer them the back that they're someone
that they should be speaking to what are
the principles to get into that point if
i'm someone that wants to be yeah
getting in front of these vcs and
building relationship and getting these
people to refer me to companies that i
can support like what are the principles
to to get into that point where i'm then
being the person they consistently refer
i think under promise and over deliver i
can't often go back to that um and not
saying you can do something if you can't
um because people kind of quickly get
found out in the market and
um i live and die by that kind of often
and certainly with the amount of work
that we that we take on it's great if
you pick up a client if you can't
deliver into it it doesn't really matter
because they're never going to kind of
come back and use you so um
we
i think the way that we generally work
and we use a lot of tech and automation
to help do our work but with with the
majority of our clients we have slack
journals with them we're not just
plugging in and just putting kind of
resumes onto a database we have weekly
sync ups we have slack messaging with
them so it's
it's definitely more of a modern
approach which you've learned over the
years it definitely didn't start that
way but um
with a lot of people hiring on mass like
yeah it's it's kind of definitely needed
okay interesting so
i guess from all the things that you've
learned it might just be second nature
now but
like did you
did you uh operate in the uk europe
markets before
yes
yeah i'm sure you like talk to people
about this if you're hiring people from
the uk and maybe haven't done this
before but what would you say that like
the main nuances that maybe
you have to maybe learn the hard way or
pick up on when it comes to like doing
business
and and being successful in the uk
compared to the us do you think
so isn't it
yeah
i think it's just a slightly different
market i think some people kind of go to
the uk or sorry go to the us and expect
it to be very similar when depends on
the area that you focus on
um and
yeah
we tended to go to california first a
lot of people go to new york first and
it's quite similar to london quite maybe
what may be more difficult to go to get
into because there's lots of recruiters
that are in office they can go to more
kind of client meetings you could build
relationships there and so i think just
in terms of the way you approach the
market um and i think um
yeah just
utilizing some of the experience you
have in the uk getting used to having
lots of lots more rejected offers
because i think generally uh with the
markets that we operate in um
you're working higher fees but also
there's more companies more
opportunities
to for kind of people to kind of go
elsewhere a lot of i had one recruiter
come over and his first 12 offers was
was rejected yeah first twelve years
first 12 first 12 were rejected when one
might go in yeah
why is it why is this
just just was a bit unlucky but
sometimes like you need to go through
some of that yeah to kind of come and
it's all about having that resistance
because someone who someone else could
kind of easily go into that and then
just be like this isn't for me i'm going
to go back and just focus on the uk
yeah yeah fair enough okay
so
keen to get into some granola is here
and then i want to talk about how you've
gone about growing this business
so just some common things that i always
get asked or the people interested in so
when i know that this isn't your entire
recruitment business and the service you
provide but like just just to be helpful
what what oh you don't have to give me
the exact number but typically what what
terms would you expect to
to sign and agree on with customers
is it is it in the 25 30 35 percent like
what what we talking what have you
typically seen
yeah so definitely recently like 25 30
on contingent uh we'll see what happens
with the market kind of make it may drop
down to 20 but typically like because of
the referrals we can yeah 25 is probably
the standard uh yeah we have yeah we've
signed a lot of clients up at 30
recently but um yeah i'd say that those
are definitely people always interested
in that and then
i've said no it's all relative but then
obviously salaries like and the fee
opportunity then tends to be
bigger
yeah so just on that i think in terms of
the salaries typically that we're hiring
people um it's probably
140 to 400k base salary um
and in terms of fees
typically our fees are like
i think average this year is like 42 but
i think typically between 40 and 110 i
think it'd be like the typical average
deal size yeah but we also do a lot of
rpos as you mentioned yeah we also do a
lot of retained work as well um so i
think not a one size fits all with
certain clients and sometimes we have a
mixture of rpo plus contingency so we're
getting double whammy different yeah for
sure
okay now thanks for sharing that because
that's always like typical
things that people ask right and
i think look what would you think about
i i see in a different way but i've
definitely seen a few people like
communicate online how
like
they feel that you are doing recruitment
in the us is also being perceived that
it's like easier
than uk i don't perceive it that way but
like i don't know what what do you say
about that because i'm like yeah
um i wouldn't say it it's easier it's
definitely different
um
but
yeah i i don't know about that um
yeah i don't think i don't think people
are making out like that for me
personally the conversation that i'm
having
is like it's just as hard
like it's it's just as difficult
just as many challenges however the
thing that why people getting excited by
it the main things that i hear you let
me know sort of what you feel about it
is one the actual rewards in terms of
like all the effort that you put in
is potentially 20 50 percent larger in
terms of the fees and these things
absolutely then then it comes down to
like
like we've all been there right this
particular uk recruitment market is so
[ __ ] saturated and it is really
competitive that isn't going to entirely
go away in the u.s but there's so that
it's just so much more vast
so in terms of like always becoming up
against the same people you might
obviously miss that and then and then
also this real reputation around the
recruitment industry and staffing it's
just entirely different to the uk or
europe where recruiters are seen as dirt
on the shoe potentially right yeah some
of the common things i continue to hear
which is why people were excited about
this opportunity it's not that it's
easier in my view i think the one big
difference is that um i look at the uk
and the us and
at university
in the uk most people fall into
recruitment no one says uh before
university they want to get into
recruitment it's always falling into
recruitment in the u.s people see
recruitment recruitment uh as careers
and they look at the whole piece of
coming in as a
uh
someone to help schedule and then they
get into a trainee recruiter into
recruiter role then they go down either
look at recruitment which is usually
sourcing side and then the sales part
that they call the business development
side so
and then you can go to internal stuff so
it's seen as a career and people want to
get into it before university i think
that's probably a big difference but
also the
the crazy like numbers uh that people
are doing and the crazy funding rounds
like you look at like a series a or a
series b company in the uk that may be
20 30 million in the u.s it's it's often
50
yeah
yeah they've got more money to play with
the vcs have asked and that's probably a
a big reason
why
the funding and yeah the hiring is a lot
more than the uk
okay and then and then before we go into
uh like you in terms of growing this
business i guess this might be sort of
come under this category but i guess a
real common strategy that i continue to
hear and talk to people about is
incubating it from the uk trying to
build traction and then going over there
what what's your thoughts on this again
i guess there's no perfect way of doing
it but if you're sitting down right now
speaking to other recruiting
entrepreneurs that that see the
potential in their markets in the us
what would your strategy be what would
you be speaking to them about that you
feel would give them the best chance of
um building a successful um team and
part of their business there would it be
doing business first in the uk and going
over there what do you think
yeah
good question i think there's there's a
lot of companies that seem to just
incubate and you can't tell on linkedin
that those companies that say they're
based in certain locations versus not uh
because yeah i mean i i think my
linkedin actually says la still so i
probably need to change that yeah
it's the first thing that changes in
that yeah
yeah exactly so um
i think that you need to have a plan and
you need to have a strategy the hardest
things is doing the hours from here and
a lot of people don't want to do the
west coast but personally there's more
business there so they go and take the
east coast and i think it's saturated of
uk recruiters that want to do the the
do the east coast but won't
yeah it won't do the west coast hours so
they just stick to kind of east coast
companies uh where a lot of our clients
kind of generally hire remotely anyway
so i think you just need a plan to be
there you need to speak to good lawyers
and um
if it ends up kind of going from okay
it's gonna be three months it ends up
being 18 months down the line but you're
seeing traction get people out earlier
um
and that's the best way like i think
it's it's definitely hard for people
that they're moving into a new so they
they
join a new company and they've got a new
company new surroundings um and
yeah kind of just starting from scratch
and not knowing the market so i think
it's always good to try and
move one of those kind of metrics and if
they can be settled in a company
understand the markets from the uk and
then move over there once i've got some
traction that's definitely the way that
i did it i would probably do it again if
i if i could but yeah but i i guess a
lot of people what is it what sort of
attraction would you be looking for like
like like out of interest would you be
looking at the billings and the
performance on that side before you go
over there you're looking at signed
terms of clients what yeah what sort of
things would you be looking at a mixture
of a mixture of them all um i think
if if you're based here and
i'm working up a roll up against you say
you're in the uk i was in the u.s and
i'm working the right hours and i've got
five hours ahead to kind of focus on
people where i can have to take calls
nine times out of ten i'm probably going
to beat you to kind of hiring for that
client because i'm i'm on the right time
zone so um i think if you're trying to
get everyone in an office trying to do
the u.s hours it's tough um i've been
there i've done it for a while um and
moved over i was in the u.s for five
years but i'm there frequently and
usually every eight to ten weeks i'm in
the u.s still so um i still kind of
still work on those time zones most of
the time because it's tough certainly
doing kind of west coast from the uk
and what would you think about like
ideal situation
that you
have sort of first people on the ground
that
you've built trust with your
relationship from the uk have you ever
had the experiences of like i know you
had a bit of an experience where you
hire someone that's experienced that is
the first person on the ground like how
do you feel about that because it seems
for a lot of people that i speak to
ideal scenarios they
the people that are the first on the
ground is the people that they
understand the culture they've been part
of the uk business they've been doing it
there and they just got that trust
element whereas might be a bit more
difficult if i'm looking for someone
like jason that's got five years
experience that can open up our us
function what do you feel like think
about that
i used to think the
the former but i actually think the
latter i think if you're going to be
focused in the u.s you you should have
your first person on the ground should
be a u.s person rather than trying to
move over a uk person into a new
into a new sector i'd hire from a
competitor and have them being the first
person um would be my preference rather
than just having someone that knows the
culture except why is that you said you
used to think the the form about why
it's because i think i at times i've had
uk recruiters we are a u.s company after
all and you should be hiring
predominantly u.s people because that's
what's going to grow the company it's
it's difficult and you add different
elements if you have to have someone
that needs to have a visa they may not
like it they may miss home so they have
to kind of come back so
i i i think i used to think the the
former because of that um and now i
would probably hire
u.s people for u.s jobs most of the time
if i could interesting
yeah okay so let's talk about how you've
gone about growing this company then and
and built the business that
that that you have i guess
what
like you obviously you've had some
dramatic growth during the kobe period
like nearly almost doubled yeah
like
was that was that always the plan to
grow
a business like this did it sort of
organically happen
it's more organically i think we could
have grown
prior to that i think we're just very
cautious with
um
not taking in any investment on
and hiring the right people
and keeping that culture
um so
yeah we definitely grew during covet
like most recruiters um i think it's
just down to demand uh to be honest uh
we were inundated and
it was probably rough for a month or so
with companies kind of like
deciding where their focus was going to
be we always have more than enough
clients that we can kind of work on we
lost on a few different projects because
they just got kind of
canned but we've always had a great team
that does new business and
we're always generating new clients so i
think we were quite fortunate with the
clients that we were working with and
they just pivoted and um
yeah it allowed everyone to work
remotely which is great and so what's
interesting about your strategy is that
you you do you only hire experienced
people typically higher experience for
careers
so that's the that's the model that
we've we've kind of gone after recently
um it tends to be
we've just recently talked about last
year
probably over the last like yeah two and
a half three years and i think if you
look at the tenure over the last two to
five years
we haven't lost people to other agencies
we may have a couple to internal kind of
companies but we've been able to have
that core team that we've kind of
trusted um and we've been able to kind
of help scale that even during a um even
during kind of covert times when people
are remote so um
yeah typically we've hired people with
experience and it's not like we're we're
going back to an office we have offices
if people want to use them we meet up
really regularly um so we did a big
christmas and summer party i was in new
york last week with the team uh we do
big incentives um and then
people go out and meet so we've got like
hubs of people in atlanta in washington
in la in miami um but we hire experience
some of our best performers of working
parents which i know probably a lot of
the people that you're speaking to
as soon as people have a kid they kind
of
back off
somewhat i think that's changing i think
i think in terms of life changing
yeah in a good way yeah i think
previously when yeah you were building
your career i think it would have been
like
oh i've gotta now choose raising my
family over my career and these things
but i think like you said around the
work from home and companies being way
more flexible i think that's completely
being put on its head
so just i'm really really curious about
this then so it's a couple of things so
just to clarify so when you say
experience what we're talking here like
like five years
decade like typically i know it's gonna
be a perfect amount but typically what
we're talking and what range of
experience sure i'd say probably three
to
twenty years of recruitment
okay cool so talk me through i speak to
so many recruitment leaders that say i
don't want to hire experienced people
because i have a become a bad traits bad
habits they can't unlearn them like what
what do you think about that
i agree to a certain point but i think a
lot of people just need to be in the in
the right environment to succeed
um and a lot of people have come in and
almost like retrained and have done
incredibly well um so
um i think a lot of the the junior
people with no experience need
hand-holding we've had some incredible
people that that have just come in and
done really well who are super junior
but i think we have a different
mentality and we work with people
and
we use a lot of tools and automation as
i mentioned earlier and um it works and
we have a balance of the type of clients
that we work with from stealth mode
companies to like uh post and pre-ipo
kind of companies so i think
yeah just because people have had
a lot of experience doesn't mean to say
that
yeah they can add a lot of value with
the experience that comes with that
what i'm sure you may have had to learn
this hard way but i guess what
what what things would you typically
look for in an interview environment
that may be red flags
that might indicate that i might join
your business jason i've got this
experience however i i really am someone
that is unwilling to learn or like not
not willing to take things on boards
like anything that you become really
good at looking out for or
non-negotiable for you
i think ego's um probably probably the
biggest thing and if for me like i can
as much as uh i may be able to work with
them if the team doesn't and if they
give a a thumbs down to them then we're
not going to hire them so it all comes
down to for us like building the right
culture and the rest will sort itself
out and um
yeah that's probably the main red flag
job hopping you can see that you've got
it
yeah i'd say that yeah coming yeah but
how do you i'm like what we're looking
for here like
that just in terms of just the way that
they come across just in terms of some
of the things saying like just just if
you can't have a beer or drink with them
or they're not going to fit into our
environment but we have a really
uh experienced kind of recruiting team
and uh we get together and and
yeah if if they don't like that person
for whatever reason then we're not going
to hire them um so i think
i know it's hard to kind of
point it out it's just something that
um
the team manages to to kind of
um yeah figure out and i think probably
another thing for us like if people are
looking for an office environment that's
not us right now so we don't hire them
um because it's not like we're going to
be
going into an office uh or the team
that's that's not the type of people
well this is this is the other thing i
really want to get your thoughts on so
so you're saying that like yeah so i
think
you're saying that what you are and what
you're not like you said you're flexible
you give people
um the autonomy their experience you
give them the opportunity to retrain and
learn and improve like how how are you
how are you approaching that learning
and and those things with these people
remotely like how how are you
approaching that because i don't think
anyone's cracked this and it's difficult
it definitely is difficult and i think
you won't have to be on the ball and um
we've just put on board a learning and
training manager who's someone that's
been with us for the last four years as
a
senior recruiter and then she moved into
a principal recruiter and then she moved
to an rpo and now she's coming back as
our full-time trainer so we're
constantly doing training with people to
upskill um and
work with people what does that actually
look like within like weekly zoom
sessions we've got a slack channel that
we can share yeah like we're always on
slack so we're a slack first kind of
company and
we often share stuff on different
channels around training and i do a lot
of the training as well um so
um that can definitely be done you don't
need to be in a classroom i think
there's certain aspects that if you're
in a a classroom or an office um and you
can look around when people doing
closing calls i think that's definitely
a benefit of being in office but um we
we're definitely used to kind of giving
people autonomy we can tell if people
are working or they're not working so
it's a constant thing that you always
need to look out for but everyone needs
to be constantly um kind of trained and
going through different scenarios
because the market's continuously
involved
so how do you
how do you go about
like
i guess how do i word this
like how have you gone about just like
what's been the approach on then like
productivity activity in in this sort of
remote setting is it just are you very
much like
outcomes based like look
like if you get this done i don't care
how you do it whatever hours like what's
been the approach on that front has it
been very sort of freeing on on that
sense as well and less structured
it's definitely not less structured like
people haven't like should know how many
profiles that or how many reach-outs
they need to do in order to get x amount
of candidates that that equate to x
amount of
interviews that equate x amount of
offers so um
we knows those numbers and it's it
it varies based on
uh experience of the of the recruiter um
versus the market that they're working
in so people know those metrics and
should know we constantly remind people
okay if you're just recruiting and
you're just putting people into a search
and they're having calls here's the
number that we expect you to kind of be
at on a daily basis
if if
if it's flagged that people aren't doing
it then we start looking into the finer
details of stuff but we give people
trust and we have slack channels for all
of various clients and we can tell
people that working with people that
aren't
yeah okay
interesting and then
what about like
you know obviously we like when we spoke
about this and like obviously you seem
really passionate about the culture you
said there around like really protecting
that culture and not hiring people that
you think could potentially damage that
culture what are like i'm just trying to
understand like what are some of the
non-negotiables that you might do you
just mention the summer party the
christmas but on the weekly daily
monthly basis what what are you doing
that you think is impacting and creating
this culture like are you doing weekly
wrap-ups with it like what are you doing
that really you feel helps continue to
build that culture in a remote
environment because i think that's also
difficult yeah what does that look like
so tuesdays we do weekly spin class a
lot of us at peliton so we do that uh
weekly yoga class we do we do a lot of
games with the team
um but a lot of a lot of the people like
a lot of us play cod uh that's how i
hired someone via cod from someone that
was referred um
yeah yeah yeah i spoke to him a couple
years ago and
first time i spoke to him was playing
call of duty the guys got me into it
kind of during uh
during covert and uh
yeah each their own that's interesting
yeah i think it's just just having that
morale and a lot of the team that's been
with us since we were when we were in in
office in la um when we were four days a
week there has kind of been felt that me
and gary um as business owners we're
more like people's friends rather than
business owners and we've had a lot of
referrals from people that worked for
different companies and and we have a
lot of internal we've got an internal
team as well um so i think just
naturally like treating people with
respect always looking to go above and
beyond giving them the best benefits out
there giving them the best commission
structures out there
giving them a platform like we're a very
diverse team and that's super important
for us super important for a lot of the
clients that we work with and they see
that
and they want to be a part of it
and then what about
again going a bit granular here but just
just curious like what's
what's the sort of approach when it
comes to
to management remotely are we just doing
like weekly one-on-ones all done on
video again is that just all done in
that way as well just saying that this
video
it's all done via video but again we
have like we we sync with the different
teams um engineering go to market data
science and energy
uh on a
every monday wednesday friday but we're
constantly going back and forward on
slack like i've muted my slack but i can
already see all the slack messages that
kind of come through uh just in in a
short space of time so yeah we jump on
to call to people um and but again we
give people people we know the searches
and you don't need to to always speak to
people on a
daily basis we have a lot of um
recruiters with families and kids and
they've got different times that that
different people work but people get it
done and um
yeah often you'll send people someone a
slap message and i'll get back straight
away so it's easy to jump on and hop on
calls with people now thanks for sharing
i'm just super curious about this like
i'm sure obviously you're sick to death
i've seen all the work from home things
and all that on linkedin but i just find
it so interesting on like yeah
yeah it works with different
environments some people want to be in
an office uh that's not the direction
that we're going in definitely not right
now um
and we still managed to meet up and it's
still a great
culture and environment so you mentioned
that around like just building a great
culture so people refer people but
what's been some of the most successful
effective ways for you to to grow this
business from an internal hiring point
with
american
people and american recruiters like
what's worked on that side
i think it's just a lot of the events
that we're doing and going to like
credible locations for incentives i
think um us seeing seeing the growth
that we've had um
not having to report to investors and
telling the story so i'm often
front and center i'm the first call that
people have i still do a lot of reach
outs probably about eighty percent of
the
uh the people that we've hired have come
from my own network we have a few uh rec
direct kind of companies but i make sure
that i'm
i'm i'm there
we have internal recruiters but if
it's more attractive to people to that i
reach out to them first if i have the
time so i still prioritize time in order
to do that uh because yeah i have
internal recruiters but um they may not
respond to those internal recruits and
they may respond to me um
yeah so i definitely make sure that i i
i'm
pushing on and
then and i've spoke to obviously look
typical uk model right lower base higher
comms
like i spoke to a few people based in
the u.s where
they thought they might be able to have
that approach in the u.s but that didn't
really work uh in terms of
what they just found is that obviously
you can go into a corporate recruitment
career where the base is is way more
higher maybe less commons if in like an
internal recruitment role
but how's that
what do you think about that is is that
something that people need to be mindful
of that they might not be able to
like expect to hire people with like
that same sort of like base salary com
split are they going to have to put more
into the base like i found that out
quite a lot from speaking to people that
are quite surprised with the bases that
people would expect
yeah i think that the market's always
continuously evolving and um yeah some
people want to go into an internal
recruitment role but i personally think
there's no better time to be an external
recruiter right now because there's so
many jobs obviously you're seeing in the
market that a lot of internals are
getting cut from small to large
companies just down to the market
conditions um so i think there's
definitely experience from both sides
both an agency versus internal roles um
but i think that the chance to work in
specific areas and work with multiple
clients is very attractive to people and
yeah we may lose a couple of recruiters
to internal roles but we kind of expect
that um but yeah like
it just depends on the personality uh of
the
the recruiter and what what stage of
their career that they're at
but i guess sorry what maybe i wasn't i
wasn't very clear sorry like have you
found
like when my my first recruitment job i
was on a 20k base right now yeah it was
coming i'm saying about 18 yeah yeah
it's a lot i was in the i was just
asking but that's really common right so
as you said it's a career in the us it's
something that people want to get into
but what i found is when i've spoken to
people that started their careers in the
uk or started their business in the uk
and went to the states is that they
haven't had as much success or it's been
as effective on like jason yeah i want
to offer you a job for my company i'm
going to give you a
much lower base and comms that didn't
quite play out that's what i was just
curious about yeah okay fine yeah i
think yeah people know they could need
to know the costings of the us because
it's expensive to hire people people at
higher base the minimum
um
yeah the lowest i think that we're on is
like 45 50k on a on a base salary and
that goes kind of up and up and up um so
i think yeah it's expensive and then if
you you put on top of that a lot of
companies pay 401k a lot of people have
we have 100
uh health that's covered um if you don't
offer that
to
um recruiters
yeah you're just going to struggle to
kind of get you're going to struggle to
get people and that can
i think with that's about 350 400 um
dollars per person per month um if they
have a family it's more so
yeah there's stuff on top of that that
kind of eats into your top line that you
wouldn't have to do in the uk so i think
you need to be mindful over the
experience that you're looking to hire
um and and also kind of target the right
locations and you may want to avoid like
san francisco new york and some of those
more expensive cities out there um in
order to kind of find people that are
maybe more reasonable with what you're
looking for
and you know like you said you got
people in all these different hubs
a lot obviously there's so many
positives of being able to hire people
remotely in different areas but like how
like it's just so vast isn't it like
you can also just get lost like where do
we start so like
have you purposely
tried to have little hubs or like look
in particular states or because like
there could be so many different places
that you can find people like how do you
yeah focus so
yeah so i think initially we started in
la um
today we're in like 14 different states
across the us
the states have just organically kind of
grown um but yeah we kind of because of
the clients that we work with in a lot
of the searches that we do like i think
kobe doped my eyes and ears to the types
of people that we could hire and um
yeah like the time zones kind of
trying to figure out everyone's time
zone can be challenging but um i yeah
i think don't always go for
people in certain states and try and
avoid those expensive states if you can
but it depends if you're hiring remotely
it shouldn't it shouldn't matter to you
if you're hiring in for a specific
location then yeah you're probably gonna
have to pay a premium
yeah not interesting so couple final
things and then let's wrap this up by
just talking about what you're excited
about what's on the agenda
i guess that this might uh we could end
up talking about this for a while to be
fair but i i have i wanted to ask you
like do you think
do you think if i'm a uk recruitment
business owner right now and typically
how i worked with people in the uk is on
a like contingent exclusive basis i
might be doing a little bit of retain
but i'm mainly working people on an
exclusive basis
do you think i'll be really missing the
trick if i don't have any other sort of
solution in the us because i think when
we spoke what i thought was interesting
was
how you said that the hiring projects
and opportunities typically with u.s
company not all the work all the time is
that you might speak to us company
they're like look jason over the next 12
months we want to hire 30 to 50 people
but maybe a uk or europe-based business
they might be saying five to fifteen do
you know what i mean so like do you i
guess what i'm trying to ask you is you
know obviously you do like rpos retained
so you think like people really need to
think about what solutions and products
they can bring to the us market if if
they want to be more successful there is
that really important or could i just go
over there and just sell exclusivity and
just work contingent what do you think
i'm not a fan of exclusivity but yeah
you could definitely do that um if you
wanted to i think you evolved with the
companies that you're reaching out to
and and i think a one-size-fits-all
approach of just going down the
contingent where looking at like
different add-ons can uh definitely help
i look at a scenario that we had when
i moved the business from like
2016 to mainly focus on the us and uh
another company that i have venture uh
was a guy that i i used to work with and
trained up and they focus now on the uk
and european because we were kind of
dipping our toes in the water with some
of those clients but i needed to move
away because our focus for intellitech
and internet tech energy was purely on
the us because that's where uh we were
getting a lot of traction so i think in
terms of um having different services so
often we're referring clients that me
what we've got in the us that are
looking to open up their first like
european or uk office and doing intros
from that side and vice versa and it
works really well um but i think that
yeah i i think to go over
in the in the us where people want to
work with you they see you more as a
valued long-term partner um
definitely you should be selling
retainers if you can
but selling a retainer isn't always the
most profitable stuff to do and so you
need to kind of consider that sometimes
working at 25 30 on contingent is
actually better um is less hassle and
you actually make more money so there's
been times where
certain projects that we've done
actually haven't panned out and we wish
that we just stuck to a contingency
agreement so um
it's not just interesting yeah it's not
the one end or with uh with working on
retainers i guess i think what you said
that i've sort of really underlined and
thought was like evolve with the
customers that you're supporting and
partnering with i think that's the best
way to approach it isn't that yes
maybe not having a one size fits all and
thinking about what those things are but
then evolving with what you're asked for
how you're helping companies
exactly we've worked with a lot of
clients that have gone from series a to
series e
uh or from series d to ipo and have sold
the company so there's different interac
iterations that kind of come with that
and
sometimes they need you sometimes they
pause for six months because they're
building an internal team and then they
come back to you so i think it's it's
you just gotta try and
think one step ahead and always be
selling to your clients and sometimes it
may not be the right time and that maybe
maybe best and then go and look for
other business so yeah it definitely
definitely goes kind of kind of goes
full circle
okay and then i have to ask you this is
one of the common things i always get as
well before we finish is
what are like must-have tech tools i've
only said a lot about automation i don't
want to give you all the secret sauce
away but i always hear about zoom info
that's one that i always hear
what what tools have you like what tools
would be you're like you know what
definitely check these out for the
american market be most effective what
are we saying don't want to give away
all the keys to the castle
um yeah but mate you can have all the
tools but it's about how you use them
zoom info i had um a while back um we
use it now for energy but we're less of
a kind of trying to make 50 to 100 calls
and more kind of
automation so i'm a big believer in
automation and i often say to the team
that if something if a task takes more
than two minutes you need to be
automating it so i've i've used like
products like talon bim which was
acquired by monster a number of years
back um
super early we used a tool called reply
which is i think very similar to source
well uh email automation is amazing for
what we do
um and yeah we use stuff like contact
out we've got a few other different
tools that we use but i'd rather keep
those on the wraps
but so you said reply i've never heard
of that
replied i
the other one was called uh talent it
was acquired by monster and it's not as
good as it was but i used it super early
but often um i have a lot of connections
in the vc world and um
a lot of them kind of come out and want
me to test like new tools so we get like
first dibs on a lot of stuff let's do
some market which is definitely super
helpful yeah okay nice love that now i
appreciate you sharing that
so
what what's what some what's on the
horizon for you guys then as we come to
an end here obviously had some really
exciting growth like if you got
obviously recently invested in obviously
the energy um brand which is really
exciting that's coming up to the first
year like what are you excited about
what what have you got top of mind over
the next 6-12 months of all the things
that's going on like what yeah how are
you feeling about things sure so it's
definitely an interesting time for the
market um
and yeah we'll see what happens there
but uh we're opening up a couple of new
areas um so we're going to be hiring for
the government and government agencies
uh we're just going through a final
approval of that
also um in the market doing like latter
stage interviews for opening up a life
sciences division uh which is excited
about that energy is a big area of our
growth um so probably expect the team to
be
five to eight by the end of the year and
then just continuing to to kind of uh
grow the team and work with the team
develop people um
yeah and are you enjoying the journey
yeah
yeah yeah sure i mean i've never worked
harder in my life than right now but
yeah super proud of the team and and
um we've got some incredible kind of
targets to hit and
yeah hopefully the markets stay
buoyant which i fully expect it too um
and yeah kind of trying to knuckle down
and crush it and
a few different initiatives that we're
looking to kind of do a few more
incentive trips that are in the works so
where
where's home for you
uh right now
like what did you
where would you call home i've
interested right now north west london
bushy um
which
would you call what do you call home is
it america is it a laser uk london like
do you know what i mean because you've
been in a few different places mate
yeah um
i'd like to
yeah i guess now that my my eldest who's
four is starting school uh probably the
uk
but we we go back and and i travel quite
frequently um anyway so um
didn't want to move back from the us but
was kind of forced to doing covet
because my wife was pregnant with our
second and haven't kind of gone back
relocated moved the dog over which is a
acid but i'm still there kind of
frequently and yeah nice i was just
curious because obviously you've been in
different parts of the world you know
yeah i wasn't sure what you would deem
as home sometimes
yeah sometimes i'm not sure either um
um as you can probably
probably tell but and you wait you got
you got the dog all the way from the us
or the uk
yes
yeah
yeah and that's been oh my god some
jokes i thought i wasn't in la to see
that kind of happen um one of the guys
was living in my house and yeah that was
horrible to kind of
think of kind of him being on a plane
during coco
but yeah we managed to get him back
nice he was he's been part of the
furniture because he used to always be
in the office
i really love that yes well um look
jason thank you so much for joining me
thanks for being really honored sharing
a lot of things i know a lot of people
find this conversation really helpful
and useful so look
like i may like kudos to you on
everything that you built so far i'm
sure there's plenty more to come but
look jason really appreciate your time
and thanks for joining me on on the
podcast thanks for having